Hey guys, welcome to a brand new video.
Today I'm going to be bringing you my
Barrows guide. Something that's been
requested actually quite a few times. Uh
now having tested uh Barrows at my level
with the Mortania hard diaries complete,
I'm getting about 1 mil an hour in
profit after my costs and stuff I've
been taken off. So I'm going to go over
my method of getting that. I'm not going
to be going over every single possible
gear setup or way to get there or way to
kill them.
Uh it'll be more of a compact guide. Uh
but yeah, so hopefully you enjoy and
let's get started. So how should you get
to Barrows? And first and foremost, I
would just recommend using Barrows
teleports. They're quick, easy to get,
and uh they don't have a requirement to
use. Uh they're only about 2.6K on the
Grand Exchange right now, and that's
going to pay for itself in how quick you
get there. You'll be able to do more
runs per hour, and I think overall they
will pay for themselves. Uh another
viable option is teleporting to Burgh de
Rott. However, you will need the
Mortania hard diaries completed just to
use the teleport. Uh so overall Barrows
teleport tabs can be used at a lower
level and are just easier. I would not
recommend
uh using any of the other shortcut
routes, like using the Myreque shortcut
or running all the way from Canifis.
It's just not going to be worth it, so
just don't do it. Buy Barrows teleport
tabs, or if you really uh want to, you
can use the Burgh de Rott teleport. So
now for the skill requirements, you will
definitely want 75 magic and 75 range.
You can get away with a lower range
level, but I would definitely try to
have 75 magic before you do too many
Barrows runs. Of course, you can do it
with less. It's just for
efficiency-wise, you'll probably want
around these stats. 70 defense is not as
important, but still pretty nice to be
able to wear any kind of Barrows
equipment. And 43 prayer is a must. You
have to have that to do the runs, and
even
a prayer level of 60 or 70 will help out
a lot more
and save you a lot more on food and
prayer potions.
Okay, so now to go over my gear setup.
I want to mention a few things, but
first and foremost when you're choosing
your gear,
it doesn't have to be picture perfect
for what I have, but keep in mind you
want to be maxing out your defensive
bonuses first as well as any items that
might increase your max hit as in magic
damage and by that I mean like
determined bracelet or the occult are
going to be good here
despite my next point. Um, and that is
that you should not be necessarily
bringing magic gear except of course for
the weapon because since the Barrows
brothers have such a low magical
defense, I think it's even negative or
zero having
even wearing a room plate body will not
affect how accurate you are
that much. You won't really notice the
difference. So, you should be maxing out
like I said your defensive bonuses. So,
if you have um,
dragon boots or even dragon armor,
that's going to be more useful for you
than wearing mystic. Mystic's is really
bad here cuz it has no defensive
bonuses. All it's going to be doing is
giving you the defense that it gives,
which is nothing, as well as magical
accuracy, which is not very useful here.
If you have 70 defense, you most
definitely should be wearing some sort
of Barrows gear.
I have a ring just because I already
have in the bank and I haven't noticed a
huge difference in the amount of damage
I take, so I just wear it
because I use it for other things and it
just makes more sense. So, now for your
offensive weapon, you most definitely
should be using a trident, whether a
trident of the seas or trident of the
swamps.
Um, obviously the toxic trident is
better
but either will do. Now, you can use
Iban's blast, but be prepared for the
whole process to take a lot longer.
You'll be doing less damage and being
less accurate. Now, you will need to
bring a range switch. I am using the
toxic blowpipe, which is by far the best
option. You can use a magic shortbow or
even a rune crossbow if you really want
to,
uh but the toxic blowpipe is going to be
the best. With it, I'm also bringing uh
some god d'hide, uh which just happens
to give a bit of a prayer bonus. Not a
huge deal. You can easily use black
d'hide and black d'hide bottoms. And you
might have noticed I just have the uh
snakeskin boots equipped as well as the
Ava's accumulator equipped just
throughout the whole run cuz it doesn't
affect your damage
uh and your accuracy. And it's just
easier to wear and just do a three-way
switch. That's the gear I'm using. Uh on
top of that, I am bringing a ring of
dueling, which is used to teleport back
to Clan Wars.
Okay, so I'm going to go ahead and do a
full Barrows run for you guys right now.
Uh just to quickly go over my uh
inventory setup. All I'm bringing is
Honestly, some pretty newbie food uh cuz
you just really don't take that much
damage, uh as well as a prayer potion, a
spade, and my Barrows teleport tabs. Uh
prayer potions will occasionally get
used, but not honestly that much either.
So, let's go ahead and teleport to
Barrows with the teleport tabs uh you
should have bought.
So, first thing you're going to notice
is that there are six mounds that you're
going to have to dig down and fight the
Barrows brothers. Now, in one of those
mounds, he is not going to be there and
you will go deeper down into the tunnel.
So, the way I start doing this is first
up, I always start with the rock. He is
the most damaging and just the most
scary, so you want to get him out of the
way first while you most definitely have
prayer.
Uh so, you're going to just dig down and
pray melee.
And now, I usually get right here next
to the ladder just because it's the
quickest to get out of here once you're
done. Uh you can see that the trident of
the swamp just rips through them very
quickly. I don't really bother putting
on uh mystic might or anything because
your prayer gets drained pretty quickly
anyway, and I don't think it's was doing
anything because your accuracy is
already so good. You might do in a
couple extra damage, but it's not a huge
deal. So, once you're done,
take off your prayer and head back up.
Now, from there, I usually just do a big
uh clockwise circle around the middle
mound, and I hit that one last.
Uh the reason I do Ahrim last is for
one, he does actually drain your stats.
I'm not really sure if that would affect
uh your magic too much, but either way,
I just do him last cuz
it's just the way I do it. Guthan's is
next. Uh same thing, you're just going
to pray melee against Guthan's. So, next
up is Karil. Uh he's going to be using
range, so you're going to be praying
range, and I still just continue to uh
use my magic attack because it does seem
to rip through Karil just as good as the
melee brothers. Uh so, no problem there.
Uh Karil is another brother that tends
to actually do quite a bit of damage as
well, so you're definitely going to want
to be praying uh the whole time against
him. The other ones you can kind of get
away with just tanking, but those do
tend to rip through
uh you a lot uh easier. So, we just end
up praying is the best way to go. Next
up is Torag. Torag's kind of a pushover.
Okay, so Torag is actually the one in
the tunnel. So, once you figure out
where your tunnel buddy is, just go back
up and ignore it for now. Uh one other
thing worth noting is whenever you're
underground, your prayer is going to be
getting drained. Uh so, definitely don't
dilly-dally too much when you're
underground
uh cuz you'll constantly be getting a
prayer drain. Next up is Verac. So, once
again, you're just going to be praying
uh melee against him. Uh although, he
his special ability lets him hit through
prayer, but you'll definitely be
reducing the damage by praying. So,
definitely, if you have the prayer
points, definitely use them. And last up
is Ahrim. Now, Ahrim's the only one
you'll actually have to be using the
gear switch for. So, here I switch to my
range gear and then go down. If you have
prayer points left, use them, but
otherwise, it's not a huge deal. Ahrim
doesn't tend to do a lot of damage.
Usually I'll just dump the toxic
blowpipe specs into him uh cuz it gives
you an extra bit of HP and just helps
you kill him quickly. And uh the
blowpipe honestly just kills
uh Dharok so quickly, so it's not that
big a deal.
And there we go. We've killed all the
brothers, easy. Now from here, now that
you're in the center, you're going to go
back to where uh the brother was missing
from. So in my case, it was Torag. Uh if
you're using OSBuddy, it has a little
nice little counter up here in case you
forget. Uh but do try to remember cuz
it's annoying otherwise. So from here,
you're going to enter the catacombs
through the sarcophagus. And now you're
going to notice that you're in a giant
room with some interior rooms and some
exterior hallways. You're always going
to spawn in a room in the corner. So
once you get down here, you're going to
want to orient yourself towards the
chest. If you zoom out, uh you will
actually be able to see which door you
can go through usually. So you can see
here, can't open it, can't open it.
Can't quite see that one, but this one
here you can see I can open. So this is
going to be the room I can enter
through. So from here, you have to look
through what doors you can actually exit
through and there's usually only one
door you can go through. And
unfortunately, right now it's an
exterior door. So one other thing you
want to keep in mind here is you can see
the reward potential
uh which right now is 54%.
So 100% will get you the max amount of
rewards. And to get 100%, you will need
to kill some of the minions down here.
I'll just say right off the bat that the
most uh profitable way to get the kill
count is just to kill three skeletons is
the easiest. It's going to get you uh
not 100%, but it'll get you the max
amount of runes possible which are worth
the most. So what you're going to want
to do is just run through the tunnel.
You'll get used to doing this more. Um
keep running through and when a skeleton
attacks you, kill it, but don't go out
of your way to kill other things and
then kill the skeleton. Just run through
and when a skeleton attacks you
automatically, just go ahead and kill
it. Here, there's another skeleton in so
I'll just go kill it and that will be
the kill count completed. You're going
to want to always be running through the
tunnel. You don't want to stop and
search for monsters. Just focus on
getting through to the chest and
normally you can get the kill count just
by running there. So I've already got
it.
Uh I'll need to only kill
um
Torag and that'll be it. So I'm just
continuing to run around here until I
get to the door. Sometimes you'll get
lucky and you can get there right away
or sometimes you got to run all the way
around uh which is a little annoying as
well. So you'll notice that this time
that Torag actually spawned in the
tunnel.
Uh sometimes that'll happen or sometimes
they'll spawn in the chest. Now I'll
normally just tank them up unless it is
Dharok or Karil. If it's Dharok or
Karil, I'll drink one dose of prayer
potion and then go ahead and put on the
respective prayer. If it's anyone else,
I just tank them cuz look I did not even
take one hit.
Sorry, I took one hit. And but honestly
not that big a deal. There we go, we're
done. Now the last thing you have to do
is know the puzzle for the door. And
this just takes practice. I'll put the
solutions onto the door. Uh but one
thing worth noting is
uh if you wait until they're just about
to hit you with and click on that,
you'll have a lot more time to figure
out the puzzle. Otherwise, you kind of
have to be very quick about it. But
there we go. That is a Barrows chest
looted and uh we actually did get some
bolt racks this time which is very rare.
When you go for 88%, you almost never
get bolt racks and you'll get max amount
of runes. All right, so that's about it.
From here, I just teleport back to Clan
Wars. And honestly I will I don't even
usually bank except for this time I
dueling ring did run out. Uh but all you
got to do is run over here to the free
for all portal, run in it, and then
teleport out, and all your stats will be
restored including prayer, HP. The only
thing that doesn't get restored is your
special attack. That's not a huge deal.
So you notice I did the entire run
without using a single piece of food or
a single prayer potion. That does happen
fairly frequently. So once you have
these stats and get used to it, you can
pretty much expect to use very minimal
amount of resources to sustain yourself.
So, now to determine how much money you
can make in hour at Barrows. So, in the
background, I'm going to be doing 1
hour's worth of chests. Uh so, it takes
me about roughly 5 minutes to do a
Barrows chest. So, that equates to about
12 per hour. Now, per chest I get around
60 to 70k in runes alone, and that's not
including any Barrows equipment you
might get. And that alone will get you
close to 8 or 900k an hour just from the
runes, upwards of a mill sometimes if
you're lucky. So, that just on its own
will make you probably after all your
costs is gone, maybe 4 to 500k an hour.
Now, this is assuming you do have the
Morytania hard diaries completed. If you
don't, you can expect to make probably
closer to uh 6 or 700k an hour just in
runes, and that's not including any of
your costs. Of course, this is just how
much you're going to be bringing in. So,
I would recommend completing the
diaries, but honestly, you can still do
them before that, and you'll still be
making decent money per hour. So, now to
talk about the uh Barrows equipment. So,
there's actually a 1 in 17 chance of
getting a piece of Barrows. So, that
equates to a piece of Barrows about
every hour and a half. So, I've gone
ahead and calculated the average price
of a Barrows item, and it's about 700k
at the current prices. So, if we take
that and bring it down to how much you
can get every hour, it's about an extra
500k an hour you should be getting on
average. Uh in this particular loot, I
actually got an item worth 400k, so it's
pretty much bang on with what you should
be getting on average. Of course, you're
not going to get a piece of Barrows
every single hour, but the cost uh when
you take into a large sample size, will
be about
4 to 500k an hour from the equipment.
Okay, so there we go. We finished off 1
hour worth of chests. Now we started off
with about 2,000
trident charges. So we used about 500
charges on the trident, which is about
250k.
So expect to use about 250 to 300k an
hour just just in trident charges. Let's
go have a look at our total loot first
here. So we're going to toss in all the
runes and we did get the Dharok's helm,
which like I explained is pretty
average. And we got some mind runes and
the Dharok's helm and 14k and some bolt
racks. So in total we got about 1,250k
worth of loot. Now we just have to
figure out our cost and to count that
we're basically going to be using one
prayer potion that we used in the hour,
12 Barrows teleport tabs and some food,
which equates to about 55k
plus
about 250k in trident charges used plus
a very minimal amount
of toxic blowpipe shots.
So in total we probably lost about 300k
in total in resources and supplies and
we netted about 1,250 leaving us with
about 950k in profit for the hour, which
is pretty average. I've done a couple
hours of this now and it roughly gets
down to about 1 mil every hour. So
anyway guys, I hope you enjoyed the
video. If you did, don't forget to toss
a like. It took a little while to record
and I will see you guys in the next
video.